[Music]
[Music]
but with colors
golly come on equal to the Belarusian
people coming from both I take you to do
it here in Brussels with bringing some
light and colors yeah thank you to do it
in Instagram Facebook from the people
for deliveries is crazy excellencies
ladies and gentlemen and welcome new
year in this centre of the capital of
Europe Brussels capital of 500 million
European citizen is very important
moment and as I said today to the artist
with his artworks that forest Bosnia
have a special history with Belgium is
very important with all the Balkan
country and we do this great moment
every year with the Balkan traffic that
nicola leads in both special place in
what it happens with Bosnians Eckerman
is very very important for us and thank
you for Ricardo to do this light in this
area I see my good friends the owner of
the gallery mr. grosser he knows what
this neighborhood is during a few years
because it's very ugly place and now
with this new housing new restaurant new
shops we rebuild this city rebuild the
center of the city and with this our
world is very remarkable to sign that
bruisers is the center of Europe editors
also a movement of the people linked
between the people together of what
happens in Brussels is very important
thank you - Ricardo for this very
wonderful art most convivial zero on
only the most famous year in Cleveland
or mogherini
year at how exceptional can fill a
commission openly say possibly mark of
methacel casually becomes it when your
pay
Pasco was a vintage Road in the cup
Coachella pub on the moment officially
but her presence would be presence on we
sell Louisville an artist the Bush years
ago v8 importance it of massive remote
la Madame mogherini velocity TiVo
molecule to Donovan said frisk same MO
he do not push the creamiest universally
severe of which the patrol car mrs.
Paparizou Rahman magnifique from
exertion Accola voila and fatigability
Balkan traffic engineer he existed about
conquer possibly sell up well label Co
seller hot seller hope is a type of
tunnel dear disavow son excellence mr.
Albin year would occur so positive copy
we know the Kapoor haupia Keystone
compact $1 BALCO it could say the whole
castle up which will become the drop or
bid no pain he's a postcode affair he
sought to block blasphemy new the pipe
along with the Malcolm X arigato thank
you very much for this artwork is very
important for us and I give the worst no
to miss his mogherini please serum a
sampler from personal common open mercy
consider Universal cam pity for Marvel
OC
I'll switch to English to thank the
artist his team his friends that I know
helped him realizing this wonderful
piece of art and also I would like to
thank the ambassadors of the Balkan
countries that are present here with us
today all together which I think gives a
signal of unity of the region that
brings us a lesson I believe also inside
the European Union I believe that you
are doing something remarkable here not
only because it is really beautiful
and this mix of colors different forms
gives the sense of the diversity of the
Balkans coming together and bringing
light and not drama or suffering which
is giving a different image of the
Balkans the image of the younger
generation of the Balkans that feels
European and that European flag there
reassures me a lot because I think that
you again not only bring to Brussels and
to Europe a wonderful gift which is this
piece of art but you also I think bring
the Balkans where you belong which is
the heart of Europe I always get very
angry and the ambassador's know that
well when some even colleagues of mine
say that we need to bring the Balkans
inside Europe or closer to Europe
because you are already not only Europe
but the heart of European history of
European geography of European culture
for good and for bad
as all of us and I believe that this
piece of Arts remarkable piece of art
that I promised you I'll bring my
daughter's also to see it because I
think they will love it I think this
piece of art brings the Balkans where
they belonged which is the heart of
Europe now it is then for us both on the
European Union level with our Member
States and with the authorities of the
Balkan countries to bring all the
Balkans insights of the European Union
this is the next step I am convinced
that today compared to five years ago we
started with our mandate four and a half
years ago I would say that today each
and every one of the six partners we
have in the Western Balkans are closer
to the European Union and I believe that
we can still use the seven months to go
before the end of the mandates of this
commission to do some irreversible steps
for each of you to get closer to the
European Union and finally in our
European Union because
for the Balkans I even have a difficulty
in using the word enlargement I think it
is really a matter of reunification of
our continents so I think that this will
be a very powerful reminder for the
citizens of not only Brussels Belgium
but also of all of Europe and the
institutions of the European Union to
complete the work of reunifying our
continents and I believe this would also
be the best way possibly the only way to
wound to mend the wounds of the war in
the region
once and for all and to do it in this
colorful joyful manner that the younger
generations of the Balkans always
Express I think you know where you
belong to and that's here so thank you
for bringing this gift to us thank you
for support I would like to thank you
mr. mayor close madam the representative
to be there and of course I'm very proud
that but can't reveal yet linked end
results and you two deserve thanks to
her though thanks to art because at the
end of the festival but can traffic it's
a traffic of co2 the emotive festival
was from the beginning thirteen years
ago to overpass about the countries from
Vulcan and Western Balkan and thanks to
couture I think that we will reach it
this a very good example thanks to
recover from Bosnia Segovia now button
traffic will open for the third
situation at the end of April here and
yes we will obviously continue our work
to bring people together because
bristles first of all is one of the most
multicultural must meet molecular city
all over Europe and is very important
for us on our nonprofit Association then
thank you again
hello I prepared a speech thank you all
for coming first of all my name is
Ricardo drue Strich and I'm a painter
from Siravo in bosnia-herzegovina I'm
the creator of this mural that you
already saw this is the biggest and my
best mural so far its title is it is
only with the heart that you can see
clearly a reference to the la petit
Prince by Antoine de saint-exupéry it
has universal message of love peace
tolerance and reconciliation I think
especially we the people from the
Balkans should look at each other
without prejudice and with an open heart
my main goal as an artist during this
creative process was to represent my
city of Saraiva Bosnia and Herzegovina
and the Balkans in a different more
positive light and a better picture that
that you are all used to hearing about
us art has many purposes and one of them
is to connect people I hope with my this
with this hard work I came close to that
ball in the end I wish to thank all for
you all of you for coming Thank You
Balkan traffic Nicholas the city of
Brussels mr. Clow's Thank You mr.
mogherini and her team for giving me
this opportunity to share my art with
the people of bristles and EU the last
but also very important very big thank
you to my friend but I mean changuk for
coming here and helping me create this
artwork thank you once more for coming
here
voila algo para uno de colegio El Santo
bear du cinéma party notepad Raymond
Avilla Monet extraordinaire ma on au
revoir au travail ET val is AC Murcia to
mark in the upper middle is a jean de
cette super darkovan ad secured new ii
like you pass me the really see the
connection jalapeño repair is a
container with a mass at a tribal
mentality which convocation diverse
repeated to name the laser massive hit a
mercy posit initiative illusion permit
the Appaloosa pudiera nevada gallery
Navajo Hopi Oscar Cockrell hope
vasoconstriction a project reckon cannot
release it wanna
inavaja inavaja PS the Constitution
asociación de colegio capilla de Levante
Jocasta to univ o dell avec dot
colleague news upon the joomla avec the
passaggio say a discreet or authority on
Chartres patrimoine not the constitute a
periodic table set Association rependa
passer dr. de
a surety si vous pouvez no metal contact
avec de pasar situated on a volcanic
pore canopy she owned a large estate
association on evolved opinions about
the contact on a span our Lord
avian a rock rocky maivia key to have
existed on the pebble connect a velocity
in petite the Lord Kesava public now
Missy vous pouvez news a policy not
approach a key a deja de passe NC
regional voila
of Commerce's Venusian ooh Yahoo
savasana a cassette beaucoup see ASCII
concern gracel a lofty desert pass pass
occurs Sam could Sharma say temple de
connected zone the traffic at campus are
in over no mr. Newsom profited in see
redeemer listed on certain pass the
Tomas are we see move along prom over
said
salud the conviviality a votre vie de ma
at for me develop or compromise your
project given determine yourself a
multitude say say Peter near incidence
honorable said if ye could put it up
dear Laura zoo constitute only a mere
City participe wallah
my name is Ricardo drue screech and I'm
a painter from Saraiva the work you see
behind is my biggest and my best work so
far well I come from a small country
named Bosnia that is mostly known by
things like war blood shred and
everything that goes with it mine gay
main goal as an artist was to come here
and show my country in a different more
positive more happy life perspective and
life
yes so also I know this part of Brussels
was known as the part that is dark with
all buildings I'm happy to be a part of
the Belgian the Bristol street art
culture now and to make this
neighborhood more happy and more
colorful the title of the mural it is
only with the heart that you can see
clearly a reference to the la petit
Prince by the Antoine de saint-exupéry
it has a universal message of love peace
tolerance and reconciliation I think we
especially especially people from
Balkans should look at each other
without prejudice and with an open heart
equity on a pisco satisfy Sasha's
complete ma atmosphere the Zetas
bussiness grasses illuminae unity
jacques tati nevada beaucoup de modo
visit tourist the german artist and
ependymal now produciton marvelous
initiative is a permit which de la Roche
the purple hopper a venomous sea
fantastic in a yard on a filet de cette
initiative with an all hand of a
lobotomist at Airbus who have a petition
resort lobby to Kamiya to Mordor I live
in Brussels for six years already but I
am from Croatia and so I know the region
very well indeed I consider myself a
part of the region of course I love the
mural I was so pleasantly surprised when
I saw it because it's so colourful it's
so rich it's so beautiful that I think
it really shows that
the art and especially art from our
countries can not only educate and show
people the history and the realities and
all of that but it also beautifies and
it also brings a lot of joy and a lot of
happiness and I think the size of it and
the colours of it it's going to be
amazing for all the visitors in Brussels
when they come here and see a little bit
a little part of Bosnia has to go in a
little part of balkans in such a huge
scale in the capital of Europe
yes I'm Christina Yahoo bristles image
support Gordon and I look over Emma a
Lisa mr. Watts cam a matram sabbatical
Sweden tetete do bulk metadata spa cocoa
yaku's Marisa cellular moralia Chimaera
salamat Nastya cheese Motorola Dali boy
Valley chin Bogart stove d'Italia
missing the advanced an upperclassman
yep we video today on malady or
unwitnessed is bosnia-herzegovina motion
now Oaxaca Valley Coalition is a Provost
early to talk about human woody Aubry
salutes with central robber
my name is boramy Levitch and I come
regionally from Montenegro but other
here at the 12 years I love living in
Brussels but I always speak about
Balkans as well people ask me about my
region and I try to present it in a
positive way what I do here in Brussels
is very interesting because I'm involved
in many creative projects I have a
platform which is called we love
Brussels which is one of the most
popular communication platforms in the
city and I use it also in a way to
whenever I can promote my region and I
will be very happy to also promote this
new morale here in the city because it's
located really in the city center and it
tells a positive story about my region
which is not always the case now when we
hear about Balkans and I think that arts
and culture can contribute to change the
image into to brand the region in a new
positive way you know any kind of weird
hobby Balcon traffickers Italy but can
tragic ends Alma nove a lot has
diminished have whistled a doozie map
aji de festival attributed Oh Cassandra
Jean Kalakuta
longshan cafeteria epigraphy no CTD
Cobra Verde Balcon dog antiderivative
cost ratio center field equal to SS Asus
allocated Utica local EDD festivals the
deepest is a Peoria community Preveza
Lumiere mo mo most likely to succeed is
aurora beautif sequester music salad all
salla gastronomy Sal giant ahora
hopelessly we sell the preciso Mesa
Lucia deserve da da da novel comes and
avocado set inane and a person of a
bosco the Subaru Sophia caduceus super
Grapher I don't wanna averman fresco
koroliov acute assembled a pariah key
via the Box years ago VIN una lip a CW e
su super multi illusions of Gazala
diversity a medical division was
Velasquez possibility
dog barking traffic UTV stool ammonia
possible papua just rasulallah saw a
real esprit solutions kana Enomoto don't
ma'am
innovative opened on under Memphis of
open p/l include monster kenapa yet
reveal a was on a traveler who's got who
voz a recipient trip to give upon telcos
collaborate camille simon quito metal
include on NQ different pathway locus in
Kalapana christo.pas no Cosima not
historic a different historic welcome on
service only no quick red shows
innovative fresh a de pasión people like
Roger Abbott really classic la salida de
festival it's rolling modular two men
so tell us why you from what have you
been doing here and what messages you
wanted to send and how it was to do this
work in Brussels my name is Ben Hammond
changuk I'm a street artist and mural
painter from Sarajevo Bosnia Herzegovina
and I'm here in Brussels at the moment
finishing this beautiful art work that
I've done with my colleague and friend
Ricardo drue Skitch it is a great honor
to be here to paint this mural and to
represent our country the way it wasn't
represented very often in the past it's
it's a big responsibility to work on the
streets where everybody can see your
work it's not just for people who choose
to go and the consumed art it's for
everybody with this work we've felt
obliged to share the positive vibes that
are coming from bosnia-herzegovina knobs
not the bad ones that usually people are
used to here with choosing these colours
and composing them the way they are
composed with these lines we try to
break the borders you know the lines
here don't represent what disconnects us
and separates us but they represent
everything that brings us together and
it's a great honor to be able to express
this in a city like Brussels is